bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors un article 24
réécrit et remplacé par un délit de
provocation à l'identification des
policiers des gendarmes
la forme a changé le font aussi alors
écoutez non on pense que toutes tailles
complaire aux syndicats qui est fort
mécontent de la réécriture nécessaire de
cet article 24
en réalité leurs proches restés dans un
s'agit de loi dont les propos est si on
y revient le rein ou concerne pas que la
plainte car ça concerne aussi l'usagé
des drones et plusieurs autorités le
défenseur des droits la commission
nationale consultative des droits de
l'homme
la cnil a attiré l'attention sur du
législateur sur l'imprécision du texte
et la précision des textes c'est
l'insécurité jury sans compter que le
délit de provocation est très proche du
délit d' outrage en réalité existait
déjà dans notre législation
donc soit on est en train de voter un
texte qui se superpose à un autre et
donc il s'agit d'un texte inutile et
comme vous le savez les lois inutiles à
cheese et quoi nécessaire comme
l'écrivait montesquieu dans les lois
soient il s'agit d'un texte nouveau mais
qui conservent leur poche et la critique
d'un contour trop floue pour être
applicable et et on se dirige vers un
désordre juridique
en tout état de cause j'espère que le
sénat qui doit examiner ce texte un
coupé 16 mars se montrera vigilant en
espèces sur ces dispositions qui pêche
par imprécision
est ce que ça veut dire qu'on légifère
trop en france
oui mais vous verrez des reproches qui
est régulier d'une vingtaine d'années
une inflation législative
cette inflation a plusieurs causes dont
celle qui est imputable au législateur
lui même qui souvent en confond la loi
qui est un outil de normes sociales avec
un moyen de communication
alors vous parlez de la cnil ans elle a
été claire elle a jugé que l'encadrement
juridique était insuffisant notamment
par rapport à l'utilisation des drones
elle avait d'ailleurs déjà fait un
rappel à l'ordre au ministère de
l'intérieur qui va qui avait utilisé des
drones et la reconnaissance faciale lors
du pour surveiller le respect des règles
du confinement la cnil exige donc des
garanties supplémentaires
quelles sont elles alors c'est 2,3 hors
d'abord limité les finalités pour
lesquelles les dispositifs vont être
employés à dire que là encore je vous
parlais d'imprécisions tout à l'heure le
texte est de porter beaucoup trop
générale donc la cnil demande à ce qu'on
précise dans quel cas les drones peuvent
être employées pourquoi la cnil s'en
inquiètent elles
c'est qu'on est en train de capter les
données personnelles des citoyens
le fait que vous assistez à une
manifestation va faire l'objet d'une
fiche de police
dès lors que vous aurez été l'objet
d'une reconnaissance faciale par les
drones ce que peut limiter votre droite
manifester parce que des gens peuvent
appréhender d'être fiché ensuite c'est
de s'assurer des conditions précises des
missions qui sont menées et qui justifie
l'emploi des drones à dire que il faut
qu'il y ait une dangerosité particulière
et elle se décrète rarement a priori
donc c'est pour dire la cnil elle dit
qu'on ne peut pas envoyer
systématiquement des drones pour ficher
les manifestants sans ce gip epinay et
enfin entouré les garanties leur mise en
oeuvre
c'est à dire un outil bien précis
c'est juridiquement ce que l'on
recherche quand on veut donc fier des
gens en train de manifester
voilà les rats que la cnil a adressé au
gouvernement ce n'est pas vain parce que
vous avez bien fait de rappeler avec
muta j'étais ski fin et le pas seulement
la cnil mais le conseil d'état a
également rappelé que l'usagé des drones
parole aux films en était parfaitement
illégal ça n'a pas empêché le préfet de
police de paris de continuer à utiliser
des drones
c'est à dire il a été contre la loi et
contre la jurisprudence du conseil
d'état
il ya donc une tendance administrative a
outrepassé les droits dont dispose
l'état à l'égard du citoyen car bond de
16 merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes avocat au
barreau de paris mercier vous